[Music]
hi Helen so why don't we start with sort
of quite a uh open general question uh
you spent quite a lot of time in your
professional life doing science
communication what first led you to that
so I it's not a very good way to start
but I'm going to disagree with the
premise of your question because I hate
the term science communication right I
think it should never be never be seen
or used ever again U we don't have
philosophy you know history
communication or Arts communication we
have historians and artists who talk
about what they do right and I don't
think that science is any different I
think if you're a scientist and you're a
good communicator you can share science
um but I think that sort of putting it
in a separate category is actually quite
damaging because it says oh science is
over there and it's weird and only
special people get to understand it and
then it has to kind of be interpreted
and we don't do that for other things in
life why do we do it for science however
it is true that I spent a lot of time
talking about science as a working
scientist and um to some extent it's
just I'm interested in ideas and I'm
interested in sharing ideas and I don't
see why everyone shouldn't share in the
ideas so and I I think that's important
and I also think that this perception
that science is um you know for people
in white coats who are very serious and
who are sort of unraveling the mysteries
of the Universe I mean I think that's
all very paced and useless basically it
first of all ignores the fact that
science is done by humans and that you
know obviously we are trained and we aim
to be objective but you can't separate
the way you look at the world from who
you are you know so so the kinds of
scientific questions that get asked and
the way in which they're answered of
course there's a cultural bias and and I
think you have to acknowledge that
science is done by humans it doesn't
take away from the quality of the
science but it is something that should
be acknowledged and I think that you
know sharing the fun things is one of
the joys of life and I think that
sharing interesting ideas and curiosity
is one of the joys of life and so
talking about science and sharing the
perspective that it gives is really
important you know there's this
perception that um science is all about
facts and that's also nonsense uh for
some you know sort of philosophical
reasons as well but but really what you
have as a scientist's perspective you've
got all these bits of knowledge that
you've learned and you've built a
worldview from them and you can share
the perspective without always sharing
all those bits of information yeah I
mean so one of the important things I I
guess about taking away this idea that
uh science is only for a stratified
group of people unlike the rest of us
that's going to be very important as we
you know move into the immediate
emergency of taking serious action on
climate change do you think there's
anything that we could be doing better
in the UK both through our formal
institutions and also through the media
um to to enable people to be involved in
that sense well I think it's important
to say you don't need to know any
science to be involved in climate action
right because it's a it's again it's a
perspective thing it's a it's a what's
your view on the world and of course
you're going to need the advice of
technical people who've looked at all
the details and you know exactly how
does a car work exactly how does a bike
work you of course of course you need
technical expertise but I think
addressing climate change is far more
about what kind of world do I want to
live in how do I want to see myself as a
citizen of planet Earth right do I want
to just be part of this kind of one-way
stream that pretends it can take stuff
from over here use it for three seconds
and then throw it and it just goes away
away over there you know do do I want to
be part of that train track which is
clearly not part not the how nature
works or do I want to look at the
natural world and say you know what it's
been here for 4 and a half billion years
all these atoms are going round and
round all the time there is no
alternative to recycling none everything
basically is made from poo I mean that's
that everything is made from waste
material all of it was something else
before and so you don't need to know you
know huge number amount of detail about
the carbon cycle or about Plastics waste
to understand the difference between
just funneling stuff to somewhere over
there that you pretend is called away
because of course it isn't that way it's
all connected or whether you acknowledge
that this everything goes round and
round you know we just so I think you
can take the ideas without the science
now of course the science trusting the
science is important because basically
climate science is like a a flight
simulator for a planet it lets us say if
we do this what will happen further down
the line and just like when a pilot is
learning to fly a plane you don't want
them to make their mistakes with a real
plane full of people you know with the
the what with how we treat the climate
we can't afford to make the mistake with
the one planet we've got so we need the
flight simulators to practice on but
then we have to trust the science that
comes out of them and there are good re
there is huge amount of very robust
science that goes into that and and we
do need to take seriously what comes out
you know if we don't stop emitting
fossil fuels we have some very serious
consequences down the line so so there
does need to be some trust in science
which comes along with understanding how
science
works so Science Education is part of it
is what I'm saying but it's not
necessary like we can't wait to solve
climate change until everyone has a
degree in science because it's just not
going to happen yeah yeah and so turning
to your your scientific research what in
your career has been something that
you've worked on that you think is is
going to be most profoundly affecting
for climate change well the thing about
climate science and the earth science
you know Earth system science is that
all of it's important and I know that's
kind of a glib answer but one of the
problems of the world is that we're like
what's the shiniest thing what's the
best thing what's the most important
thing and sometimes you need that
perspective but actually the the reason
that that science works is that loads of
people are doing all the little things
everyone's putting a brick right right
and then eventually you have a building
and you can't say if that brick didn't
exist then the building would fall down
but you can say if there were no bricks
there would be no building so you know
the science that I work on is to do with
um how the ocean basically takes a deep
breath breath at Sea during a big storm
and it's to do with the breaking waves
and Bubbles and the things that I do
involve measuring what's really going on
you know seaf farers have looked out
over stormy seas for centuries but they
couldn't see what was happening 10 cmers
below the surface and and that's because
the surface is moving up and down by 10
MERS you know it's enormously difficult
to get at so my work is associated with
like what's happening in there but I
understand that's just one brick yeah
and and it's always like that you know
we talk about Geniuses and these big
ideas but really everyone is only ever
putting a brick and sometimes you might
get you might have a particularly
exciting or shiny brick but it's all
just another brick right so we're all
part of it it's I I so I don't have this
sort of hierarchical view of this part
of science was more important than this
part partly because you know there's
papers I wrote 12 years ago that no one
cared about and then suddenly there's
some new industry has come up and
they're like oh that's what we need to
know right so so I'm not really on board
with this kind of
ranking pieces of science CU we don't
know that's the point they're all there
waiting for to be useful yeah brilliant
so um moving on to the sort of the the
sociology of the practice of science
you've spoken before about the
importance of diversity in the people
who are trained a scientists practicing
Sciences what what is the importance of
diversity why why why should that be
such an important thing to Champion so
it comes back to that thing about
science being about perspective you kind
of need two things you need the basic
building blocks of knowledge to know
where you're going but then you need the
perspective is like the shape of the
house right so and everyone's experience
is their own sort of set of bricks right
their own set of where their experiences
came from so they see The World Slightly
differently they take the perspective
built by all those bits of knowledge and
they shape it slightly differently based
on their experiences and so you get
different questions depending on what
shape you build and that's what
diversity is fundamentally I mean it
comes in two forms one is that you want
the best ideas in the room and that
means you don't want 50 people who have
exactly the the same idea CU they've
built their knowledge house in exactly
the same way what you want is people
who've taken the same bits of
information built them into 50 different
things and they've all got 50 different
ways of asking the next question so so
one part of it is that these are Big
serious things to address and we need
all the ideas we can get and of course
the other part of it is
that we humanity is a team we don't
always behave like it but we're all on
the planet together and this is all
we've got and so um we need to feel like
we're part of that team and we need to
feel that people like us are in the room
when things are discussed and we need to
feel that you know somebody who lives my
kind of Life on my kind of street was in
the room when they decided whether or
not cars were allowed or bikes were
allowed or there was going to be a new
bus route right um and a lot of this is
going to come down to like little
nitty-gritty stuff like that and so that
that feeling part of a team feeling like
people like you of a part of this that's
what you need to bring everyone on board
to do it together so it so it kind of
comes into two flavors yeah absolutely
so then in with regards to the practice
of science and the institutions that are
involved universities and I suppose
educational institutions all the way up
the age brackets um what what are s of
some concrete practices we could be
working on to to achieve this diversity
in practicing
scientists it comes it it happens all
the way along I think one of the
difficulties with diversity and science
at the moment is that because there's a
long kind of conveyor belt of where
people go everyone can always blame
everyone else on the conveyor belt right
universities can say oh well not enough
students applied schools can say oh well
these students don't think they're
wanted over there you know everyone can
blame everyone else so the the first the
most important thing is that we've got
to stop blaming everyone else and and I
think and this is generally true for a
lot of climate questions is everyone's
like oh well they didn't do a thing and
it's the most destructive and time-
wasting thing possible Right never mind
them like fine Vote or protest or
something if you can change what they're
doing but the most important thing is
you change what you can do in your bit
of it so so for example um just
listening to people is the most
important thing you know if some if
someone comes into a room and perhaps
they don't feel quite comfortable
because no one else looks like them or
no one else is their age or whatever it
is the one thing everyone can else do is
actually listen to them before they
start talking and in a way that's the
the most important sort of opening step
to diversity because if people because
if you want to welcome people in if you
don't listen to them how are you going
to know whether they feel welcome or not
how are you going to know you know
whether something you just said offended
them in a way you didn't know that you
could learn about you could do better
next time so I think the you know in
terms of concrete steps I think it
really does start there like if you want
people in the room go and find them
where they are and listen to their ideas
about why they're not in your room and
then do something about it right right
and so to to to ask a slightly more
biographical question what were your
early experiences with science that led
you to pursue the career that you've
pursued so I was very fortunate in the
sense that I had parents who were um
neither of them thought of themselves as
particularly bright or well educated but
they weren't afraid to ask questions
right so if I when I was a kid you know
and I would say what's that do and they
would say oh I don't know let's go to
the library and find out let's go and
look in a book Let's plant it and see
what grows and I think you know almost
more than any of the formal education I
got growing up with that was really
important eventually my mom said to me
well I don't know you go off to
University and get a degree and then
come back and tell me I think she
possibly didn't appreciate quite how far
that was going to go but um you know um
but that sort of so so they they weren't
they they never said oh you're not
supposed to ask that or I haven't got
time to answer it they're busy they were
busy parents I'm sure sometimes they did
say I haven't got time to do that now um
but the other thing is they just said do
your best they didn't ever say oh we're
going to be disappointed if you don't
get an A or we're going to you know like
we have expectations they just said do
your best and that was one of the most
empowering things I think that I never
felt under pressure to do well and I did
if you look at my exam results do very
well but I had the freedom to do very
well because no one was like shoving me
right right and and so that thing of you
know you do your best and that's enough
and I think that in life you know that's
all you can do right you you you have to
try but you can do your best and when
you've done your best you have to say
well that was what I did and that's all
right so and in a sense there's a much
wider lesson here um which is you know
fostering a supportive space for an for
a curiosity that one hopes will be there
anyway um is really the key and that I
suppose goes for people who will become
interested in science and maybe become
formerly trained scientists or anyone
else really who does anything else I
think one of the things and my dad used
to he used to embarrass me as a kid but
I would I don't have children but if I
did I would totally do it now is he
would just sort of you know wander up to
people and say what's that then you know
or someone or or I'd say oh there's this
person over there and I really admire
them and he just want he' just toddle up
to them and say oh you know and um and I
I was so afraid of um imposing myself on
the World in being where I wasn't wanted
I I felt I had to justify my existence
like I knew I could do things but I
wasn't confident about walking into a
space unless I knew somebody wanted me
to be doing that thing right um and and
I think when you see people who are just
not afraid to just walk into situations
and go oh hello who are you you know
that those little things and I think
especially in the diversity a lot of a
lot of it is self-censorship but it's
not unreasonable self-censorship it's
because they've seen what happens when
other people do that and it doesn't go
well yeah and and actually the lesson is
you don't know unless you try yeah you
know you walk up to 10 people maybe nine
of them are rude to you one of them
might be nice and it's not that you
should have to suffer through the nine
but it's that if you if it's just like
water off a duck's back a bit well
that's an idiot don't want to talk to
them anyway you give yourself a better
chance of getting somewhere interesting
and it's it's finding ways to show
people that it's okay to fail before
they succeed considering you are here
with us how the light gets in um and
people have come to watch you speak and
debate and be involved in this event
have you had anyone come up to you like
like you said that your father used to
do and say oh you know I just want to
talk to you about your work oh like what
what did you mean when you say this um
well I didn't know my partner's in The
Green Room doing it right now I think
speakers so you brought you brought
someone to the festival who's doing that
so he's not doing that while I'm doing
giving talks um no so there were and
actually it was very interesting there
were so I gave a schools talk this
morning about the ocean and most of the
people in that room were Humanities uh
you know sort of slightly on the
humanity side which is fine but what was
interesting is they were then teaching
me about the philosophy of ancient
Greece and the history of um you know
civilizations in the past that have had
various relationships with the ocean so
I told them what I thought about the
ocean and then they came up to me and
said oh I've got questions about that
but then there was this like tribe in
ancient Greece that had a particular I
don't know the Philistines or someone
had a particular relationship with the
ocean right and so
the point is that they fine they came to
ask me a question but I also learned
something from it so that's the great
thing about these festivals isn't it
that going up to talk to the speakers
afterwards is always the the most
interesting thing but I'm learning as
well in a lot of those cases that's the
important thing to to say well good
hopefully that's a sign that it's
working because I think the idea is that
everyone learns from everyone else
audience and speakers alike brilliant um
well thank you very much for coming
Helen you're very welcome thank you nice
to
talk